they think they've got this screwdriver
and then you'll hear them saying this is
really weak and I'm thinking you better
believe is weak there's alcohol in it
my name is Augusta Gayle and I have been
bartending on and off for seven plus
years now hey I'm Kim Montgomery jr.
I've been a bartender since 1998 but my
bartending has been a little different
from everybody else's because I have
always got into the homes of the big
billionaires in the world I have to be
very honest with you if I find them
attractive I make it strong if they're
really polite about it if they're
regulars I'm more apt to you know give
them a little extra otherwise I usually
charge them and then I pour my other
shots the best way to get a free drink
out of me is to be nice to me just be
really nice it depends on the bar to
some bars are cool with you giving away
alcohol some of the mark a lot of times
yeah you have a comp tab which is maybe
twenty-five to fifty dollars where you
can bring in drinks that the bar and
management cop at the end of the night
that you've given off the regulars or
people who come in and are really nice
and you want to have come back to the
bar the only way to really get them
though is if I think you look good and
you come across pretty nice what the
hell I'll pour you a couple drinks
sometimes people come to the bar they'll
have an ID that says twenty I don't
really think so so I tell those kind of
people regardless but they order you
know what let me make you a specialty
drink I used to have a bottle with clear
liquid which they thought was maca
because it was in a vodka bottle it
really was just water with a little
orange juice whatever they think they've
got this screwdriver and then you hear
them saying this is really weak I'm
thinking you better believe is weak
there's alcohol in it the only time I'd
really secretly give someone a
non-alcoholic drink is they were just
far far too drunk sometimes you can get
away with making like a soda water with
like some lime and being like here you
go here's your tequila soda but usually
I try to just cut people off and be
straight with one drink in particular
the Bloody Mary that drink is the drink
that I found
people would be like very picky you know
do you have Tabasco do you have this
kind of pepper do you have this Adi here
mojitos are getting worse no one likes
to muddle muddling is where you take
fresh herbs or fruit they get a mojito
it's gonna be mint and simple syrup and
you muddle it with this big stick that
you like crush the mint with and you get
the flavors out and everything and
honestly they're really not that hard
it's just become like a bartender thing
to hate mojitos another drink that
people are very very particular about is
an old fashioned if they're an older
person they know specifically what they
want so I would just say you know what I
don't have this I don't have that and
that would be the end of that I enjoy
making craft cocktails so I don't mind
really making elaborate drinks again it
kind of depends on the day if you've
made like 18 really elaborate drinks in
a row sometimes she was like oh my god
please don't order another one but such
as the life of a bartender
my biggest customer pet piece is sir can
I have a drink oh man people who don't
pay just why you take credit cards and
you start a tab any number of times I'd
turn around and go no and getting right
back to the next person I had that's
just rude sir sort of a pet peeve sort
of entertaining is when people get
really drunk and just start pretty much
fornicating on your bar and you're like
no please I don't want to see this like
I'm happy for you but maybe you know
take this somewhere else where the rest
of my bar patrons don't have to watch
you making out and grow pink I love
bartending I genuinely find joy in the
human element the joy that I found in it
was eavesdropping I'm also a writer so a
lot of the interactions I have find
their ways into like my stories you see
people at their weirdest their most
vulnerable their messiest their worst in
their best and there's something really
beautiful about that and you get to kind
of take it all in and facilitate it as
the bartender one of my favorite
favorite stories is I met this home of
very very very famous what is he he's a
music manager at the end of the night
all the guests go except for about four
or five and he asked me could you just
go into my bedroom and hold a bottle of
champagne I go in I hold this bottle of
champagne who walks into the bedroom
first
but the
my life when I was 13 Farrah Fawcett she
comes in she lies across the bed her
best friend comes in all night it's just
me pouring champagne as they laugh and
talk and I kept thinking should I tell
her how much I used to live when I was
13 but I didn't I didn't want to freak
her out but I was in the bedroom with
Farrah Fawcett pouring champagne
you don't know it's anyone out there who
is going to a bar goes to a bar and
could to your bartenders a lot of us
really love what we do and you guys are
the reason why so come in and be nice
and we'll be nice to you and maybe give
you free stuff
[Music]
you
[Music]